[MUSIC PLAYING]
INTERVIEWER: How do you
translocate a three ton rhino?
The answer-- with a small
army of people and a lot
of elephants.
[ELEPHANT TRUMPET]
NILANGA JAYASINGHE: So
translocation of this magnitude
is a tremendous effort.
We have seen a total of about 35
elephants and about 250 people.
INTERVIEWER: That was Nilanga
Jayasinghe, a program officer
for the World Wildlife Fund US.
She participated in
a conservation effort
to translocate five greater
one-horned rhinos for Nepal's
Chitwan National Park
to Bardia National Park
in order to establish new
breeding populations by 2018.
But in order to capture
the vulnerable rhino,
the animals have to be
coerced into an open clearing.
That way the team
can get a clear shot
to dart and sedate the animal.
According to
Nilanga's colleague,
Dr. Shant Raj Jnawali, without
the help of pachyderms,
this task would be
virtually impossible.
DR. SHANT RAJ JNAWALI: Our
elephants are especially
trained for general work.
Without an elephant,
it is impossible.
The grasslands here in Chitwan
are the most tallest grassland
in the world.
INTERVIEWER: But maneuvering
a rhino into an open space
in such dense vegetation still
takes some skilled coordination
by the elephant-mounted team.
NILANGA JAYASINGHE: When
a rhino is discovered,
they will communicate,
the the elephants
will move in in a circular
formation around the rhino
to keep it from running away.
The technician who
is darting the rhino
has to climb up on a tree
to get a steady shot.
But once it's darted,
everything moves very quickly.
It's so rapid because you
want to make sure there's
minimal impact to the rhino.
Ideally, it should be
done within a half an hour
from the time the rhino's darted
until it's taken to the truck
and woken back up with antidote.
INTERVIEWER: The
translocation project
is just another
example of Nepal's
exceptional conservation
success story with the greater
one-horned rhino.
Primarily found in the Terai Arc
Landscape of India and Nepal,
and the grasslands of
Assam in North Bengal,
today there are around 3,500
of these rhino in the wild.
Nepal alone is home
to 645 individuals.
And while this
number may sound low,
it is a colossal improvement
on what the population was just
over a decade ago.
Concerned about the chance
that they could lose the animal
for good, the Nepal government
established the Wildlife Crime
Control Bureau.
Aimed at cracking down
on illegal activity,
the law enforcement task
force included the Nepal army
and the Nepal police.
But the biggest
impact on conservation
has come from ordinary citizens.
In 2008, the government
handed almost one third
of the country's forest to
local communities to manage,
encouraging them to set up
their own anti-poaching units.
Today there are around 400 of
these units across the country.
As Anil Manandhar, the country
representative of WWF Nepal
explains, such programs
have fostered a nation
of conservation students.
ANIL MANANDHAR: We
work with the army.
We work with the intelligence
bureaus, with the police.
And more than anything,
we work very closely
with the local communities.
And also in the family
now, conservation
is paying back to
the people, improving
the quality of
life of the people
through ecotourism,
wildlife tourism.
INTERVIEWER: Nepal's initiatives
have been so successful
that in early 2016
the country marked
their fourth 365-day period
of zero poaching since 2011.
And with the translocation
of each rhino,
there is hope that new
breeding populations
can flourish in Nepal.
However, for the team that
helped coordinate the move,
that moment of release
can feel bittersweet.
DR. SHANT RAJ JNAWALI:
Release is very emotional
because you have worked real
hard to capture these animals.
And then, like in
24 hours, that rhino
gets into deep of your heart.
INTERVIEWER: But these feelings
are usually short lived.
What matters to the
team is that Nepal
continues to lead
by example when
it comes to rhino conservation.
NILANGA JAYASINGHE: We
hear of doom and gloom
in conservation every day.
Species being killed here,
habitat being lost there.
But we have to
celebrate our successes.
INTERVIEWER: If you head over
to the brand new Seeker VR
channel, you can
experience what it
was like to be a part
of the rhino project.
Check out this incredible 360
video now by clicking here.
NILANGA JAYASINGHE: Conservation
here has been very successful.
There are more than
600 rhinos right now.
The idea is to establish
new populations of rhinos
in places where they
are no longer present.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
INTERVIEWER: Thanks for
watching and please subscribe.
[MUSIC PLAYING]